Hey, here's just wacky video.
Wisconsin Republican State Senator Glenn Grothman
is not big on masks, and he introduced Donald
Trump at the Wisconsin state Republican convention
on Saturday.
Masks were, of course, optional.
Only a few masks in the crowd of hundreds
of people.
Glenn showed up after tweeting pictures of
himself out and about earlier in the day,
not wearing a mask.
Of course, he shows up and he tries to introduce
Donald Trump and he immediately goes into
an uncontrollable coughing fit.
The cough racking his entire body the way
coronavirus is known to do.
I believe at one point you actually hear someone's
someone shout from the crowd.
Are you okay?
You have to see it to believe it.
He actually has to start loosening his tie
because of the degree to which he's coughing
violently.
It's time to talk about Donald John drug.
OK.
Yep.
OK, guys, this is how Corona virus spreads.
I'm not saying he has coronavirus, but it
spreads when anti masc people are around other
people all day and then they're coughing in
public.
I'm not saying that cough.
I don't know how close people were sitting.
Maybe that cough doesn't give it to anybody.
But Wisconsin is increasingly in trouble.
If you look at their case numbers, cases are
spiking, hitting their highest seven day moving
average today with four days in a row of record
high cases.
Now, the event organizers are saying or they
said earlier, if you have symptoms, you shouldn't
go.
The event organizers said we will make available
face masks for people who want them.
Almost nobody wore a mask, incomes this guy
and he's coughing uncontrollably.
You really can't fix stupid.
And this is why we aren't making progress.
And I know people I already said it.
People are going to write and say, David,
you know this this guy probably doesn't have
corona virus.
Layer one is even having this event.
You just shouldn't have this event.
There's no reason to have this event right
now.
Layer two, if you have the event, require
the mask, say, to the NASA required.
I guess that's considered taking away people's
freedoms.
On the Republican side and then layer three
is this specific guy coughing uncontrollably.
He's an invited speaker, not wearing a mask.
And he's setting the model that it's OK to
be going around in public coughing with no
mask.
It's stunning, stunning idiocy, the likes
of which we hopefully will never see again
in leadership in this country.
Trump finally wore a mask over the weekend,
and I hope to talk about that tomorrow.
But, you know, the Trump people are now they're
all over the place on Trump wearing the mask.
The people who think masks aren't necessary.
Don't know how to react because Trump now
is wearing one.
Is Trump stupid to wear it?
Then there's the people who think that the
masks are something the left is bullying people
into if they see Trump wearing it.
By definition, Trump must not really be that
alpha because he was bullied by the left into
wearing a mask.
If Trump insists the pandemic is over, why
did he just now start wearing a mask?
His followers are completely flummoxed by
Trump wearing the mask.
But this is all part of the big picture.
It's setting a model fought for what it is
that people should and shouldn't be doing.
And Glenn Grothman here hacking uncontrollably.
Not good.
Not good whatsoever